JOHN DEAN: Gentlemen,
the President needs
men of action.
Your new mission
is to make sure
he wins this election.
What are we talking about here?
JOHN:
Sabotage, espionage.
Infiltration,
bare-knuckle tactics.
Same shit they do to us
every election.
SPEAKER: We have recruited
covert operatives
to plant surveillance inside
the Watergate.
KROGH: You are White House
employees on the payroll.
For God's sake,
don't get caught.
(LAUGHS)
♪ ("EVIL WAYS"
BY SANTANA PLAYS) ♪
E. HOWARD HUNT:
We'll be laughed at
as third-rate burglars forever.
-(CAMERA SHUTTER SNAP)
-REPORTERS: Mr. Hunt!
People need to understand
why we did what we did.
Sometimes,
I find it confusing.
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
And we did it.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
(SIRENS WAIL)
Why is the FBI here?
Howard, we are well
and truly fucked!
HOWARD:
They should fear me.
I know things that could tear
this country apart.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
Who really killed JFK?
Oh, Christ.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪